gilles emmanuel jacquet bonsoir merci
d'être avec nous sur rt france alors les
talibans world is he ont donc donné une
conférence de presse cet après midi ils
ont notamment assuré qu'il souhaitait
entretenir des relations pacifiques avec
les autres pays cette volonté
pacification des talibans est là quel
but
bien les talibans il faut se souvenir
qu'ils ont une image de finalement assez
sombre suite pouvoir qu'ils ont eue en
afghanistan durant la seconde moitié des
années 90
donc maintenant c'est un peu un test un
test de légitimité politique pour les
talibans pas seulement auprès des pays
qui les ont soutenus un pakistan au
qatar mais auprès des pays occidentaux
les pays membres de la coalition de
l'otan de l'isaf à la france la grande
bretagne les états unis et puis aussi un
test en particulier envers la chine des
responsables talibans se sont rendus
récemment chine cherchait elle rate
sauver le gouvernement chinois quant à
l'avenir politique et économique de
l'afghanistan ils ont appelé des
investissements chinois en afghanistan
et de même la russie regarde ce
changement de boire avec une certaine
méfiance manque à une certaine prudence
lui égard notamment en raison
d'interventions passé ses dix ans de
construit à l'époque soviétique et puis
aussi eu égard aux effets que pourrait
avoir ce changement de nous voir en
afghanistan tant sur l'asie centrale
pour autant on l'a vu un beaucoup
d'afghans souhaite aujourd'hui quitté
leur pays il y a notamment en occident à
des inquiétudes concernant les femmes à
quoi nous va-t-on s'attendre pour la
peau les populations locales à l'avenir
c'est une situation extrêmement volatile
gens soient aussi
d'anciens collègues d'aller sur place
des informations
assez parcellaire les talibans essaye de
rassurer la population en particulier
les femmes et vous avez chez de
nombreuses femmes notamment des femmes
qui travaillaient dans différents
secteurs des entreprises des universités
pour l'état une crainte une crainte de
voir leur liberté et leur statut
retourner à ce qu'il était au cours des
années 90
vous avez eu des viols ont été rapportés
durant la pensée des talibans ces
dernières semaines donc il ya une très
forte crainte chez les femmes par
rapport à leurs futures conditions et
encore une fois les gens gardent en
mémoire ce qui s'est passé de ne rentrer
qu'atlantis jusqu'à de ménage qui a chip
de pouvoir en pleines vacances les
atrocités qui ont été commises et puis
application très stricte delà de la
charia qui est très dur de savoir ce qui
va se passer à l'avenir les talibans
comme vous l'avez rappelé on essaye
d'empêcher les appelants de cuir et de
rejoindre les rebords puisque ce
mouvement de masse une migration de
masse a clairement montré que la
population une bonne partie de la
population en tout cas et à kaboul
avait des craintes quant à l'avenir
politique
qui s'annonce va justement sur la
question migratoire le chef de la
diplomatie josep borrell a reconnu un et
a appelé au dialogue avec les talibans
pour éviter alors à la fois une
catastrophe humanitaire mais aussi
migratoire est ce que cette question
migratoire elles pourraient être
finalement à levier de pression des
afghans sur l'europe
oui c'est vrai mais vous savez c'est
malheureusement la question migratoire
est un levier de pression pour notre
pays la vie à une époque avec quelqu'un
d'affilée puis la turquie de vernon
annecy utilise parfois la pression
migratoire entre les pays occidentaux
comme plombier politique les talibans
pourraient le faire mais en même temps
nouveau gouvernement taliban d'avoir
très vite se rendre compte que sans les
forces vives du pays surtout ces jeunes
hommes particuliers soient vos origines
antiques 800e l'avenir économique et
politique du pays aussi sera très
incertain parce qu'il représente
justement les forces vives la population
active du pays et ses migrations de
masse c'est qu'on pourrait dire une
forme de d'élections et de vote avec ses
pieds confiants les un tableau indiquant
tout cas qu'il ne se sent pas en
sécurité
avec un régime d'aller m'en voulait
vautier vous avait résidé en afghanistan
en 2012 en 2013 vous imaginez un tel
scénario vous l'avez vu venir en tout
cas ces dernières semaines
oui malheureusement je n'ai pas été
surpris je m'attendais une forme en tout
cas d'effondrement dans plusieurs
régions comme ça s'est passé en
plusieurs provinces et pour kaboul
c'était là qu'on a connu et ce qu'il y
aurait un siège quelques combats
sporadiques ou un effondrement comment
l'avenir ces faits cet effondrement avec
ashraf ghani ahmadzaï qui a fui au
tadjikistan à l'époque les gens 2012
2013 la situation sécuritaire était très
mauvaise et très dégradé dans l'ensemble
du pays il y avait des cas de désertions
de soldats des cas aussi de soldats de
policiers afghans qui attaquaient leur
collègue ou alors que les jeux d'hier
locaux ou étrangers la situation était
déjà très préoccupante et avec certains
collègues dans les projections de moyen
et long terme que nous faisions
nous envisagions oui un tel scénario
malheureusement oui alors il ya aussi
l'avenir des afghans qui ont travaillé
pour la france est ce que certains
pourraient rester sur le carreau est ce
que tous pourront être exfiltré et
qu'est ce qu'il reste véritablement sur
place
alors le président de la république
française emmanuelle part annoncé que
l'ensemble des avions qui avaient
travaillé la france avaient été
rapatriés et hylas 1 donnait un chiffre
de 600 personnes si tel est le cas je
l'espère à l'époque j'avais été
confronté en 2012 au cas d'un étudiant
qui avait servi l'armée française qui
était menacée et qu'ils n'avaient pas le
voir sortie pas d'échappatoire il avait
servi l'armée française pendant plus de
dix ans et
à l'époque c'est monsieur pajolec été
ambassadeur de france à kaboul et qui
par la suite a occupé des fonctions dans
deux semaines en france et qui à la paix
fait pression sur le gouvernement pour
que la france a calé un certain nombre
d'interprètes mais pendant quelques
années suite à cela il y avait un
certain nombre de personnel afghan de
l'armée française notamment qu'ils
étaient très inquiets quant à leur avis
mais ce n'est que très récemment que la
france s'est décidée à agir à les
exfiltrer car n'oubliez pas aussi la
france a quand même une mémoire
douloureuse par rapport au passé de ces
auxiliaires militaire en partie en
indochine et surtout pour le cadet des
harkis en algérie alors lors de la
conférence de presse on a entendu des
talibans qui se voulait rassurant à la
fois pour les pays extérieurs mais aussi
pour les afghans est ce que il reste
néanmoins sur place une frange qui
souhaitent encore combattre les talibans
c'est possible vous savez il est dur de
prévoir ce qui va se passer il est
possible qu'un conflit armé reprennent
ce ne serait pas dans l'intérêt des
talibans et dans de l'ensemble du peuple
afghan mais il y à des efforts s'il y
avait à quelques mois quelques semaines
aux cibles fils de l'ancien commandant
ahmad shah massoud d'état jean du pin
chill qui en tout cas les exprimer leur
opposition à un retour au pouvoir des
talibans et il ya de très fortes
craintes aussi dans la communauté hazara
par rapport au tour des talibans
certains groupes pourraient reprendre
les armes
s'il considère à un moment que les
talibans comex trop d'exactions et que
leurs régimes redevenir ce qu'il avait
été dans la deuxième moitié des années
90 les d'aliments sont conscients c'est
comme ça qu'ils essaient aussi de
rassurer la population et de se montrer
responsable la manière dont ils vont
reprendre le pouvoir l'exercer au cours
des prochaines semaines et des prochains
mois et
leur amnistie s'il est réellement
appliqué ce que nous verrons bien ce
sera là que nous serons à croire nous
attendre avec les talibans est aussi
nous verrons quelle époque sera
peut-être la réaction de certains
groupes de la population afghane y
aura-t-il une réaction à nice ce n'est
pas aussi pour conclure 1 il y aura
quelques secondes on imagine mal
néanmoins la communauté internationale à
venir en aide aujourd'hui vu la
situation à cette frange qui
s'opposeraient aux talibans aujourd'hui
oui tout à fait puisque ce serait une
forme d'ingérence à cette épatante qui
pourrait même être enrobé de vidéos
noble et de principe légitime
malheureusement dans ce serait très
difficile on voit que les talibans
commence à être reconnue petit à petit
en tout cas on se faire cette idée là
donc ça serait très contre-productif de
la barre des occidentaux mais ce n'est
pas à exclure des opérations spéciales
en quelques années quelques mois seront
pas exclus merci beaucoup gilles
emmanuel jacquet pour votre éclairage je
le rappelle vous êtes chargé de cours en
relations internationales et analyste à
l'institut international de recherche
pour la paix à genève